bonsoir Eva
[Applaudissements]
la technologie
Jean-Michel ça va oui
excusez-moi c'est une posture vous voyez
il va y avoir quatre étapes la première
ça va être de se regarder les yeux
ouverts comme pour photographier le
visage de l'autre regarder les yeux
fermés je sais pas si c'est possible
regardez devant vous Bernard dites moi
qui est la personne à vos côtés est-ce
qu'elle représente pour vous qui est
cette personne moi je la connais cette
femme là
c'est pas votre épouse
et puis mardi après-midi
urgent alerteforme Michel Polnareff est
entre la vie et la mort fin d'après-midi
il va mieux il est tiré d'affaire je
suis pas médecin mais c'est bizarre
cette communication très alarmiste
suivie d'un message rassurant sur l'état
de santé de Polnareff
si vous voulez avancer ne devriez vous
pas commencer par vous excuser auprès du
peuple britannique pour ce qui vient de
se passer
sur les marges de Downing Street quand
je suis devenu premier ministre vous
avez parlé d'erreur je dis que des
erreurs avaient été commises personne ne
s'est excusé
je comprends tout à fait je respecte le
fait que vous fassiez une enquête que
vous posez des questions ça paraît tout
ça me paraît tout à fait normal mais je
trouvais quand même très très méfiant
par rapport à la vérité parce que quand
même on peut pas demander au docteur
Sioux qui m'a sauvé la vie et j'espère
que vous êtes content qu'il l'ait fait
je suis devenu addict je suis Fighter
et alors comme on nous a gratifié d'un
centre de shoot à 150 mètres du théâtre
près de la place Pigale près de la place
Pigale j'y vais une fois par mois et je
leur dis allez une petite
et ça me porte tout ça cause un virus
chinois et dans ce quartier populaire de
2 millions d'habitants les gens sont
emploie très chez eux
ne sortez pas de chez vous n'allez pas
voir les voisins
et gare à ceux qui s'aventurent en
dehors de leur appartement et sans
masque cette femme est prise à partie
par les autorités sanitaires le ton
monte elle se retrouve ligotée à genoux
pour l'exemple
pasteur on a des exemples qui marchent
puisque à l'hôtel de ville de Paris en
installer le virus de la dengue
[Rires]
et voilà
si vous nous regardez ici à Pékin la
capitale les tests PCR sont quotidien
pour tout le monde
dès qu'un cas positif et découvert les
autorités confines toute une résidence
et embarque Manu military comme ici le
patient même asymptomatique
défaillance chez Tesla le constructeur
rappelle 320 000 véhicules aux
États-Unis en évoquant un problème de
feux arrière se rappelle intervient
quelques jours après la course folle
d'un même modèle de Tesla en Chine le
constructeur a affirmé qu'il ne
parvenait pas à freiner le conducteur a
dit qu'il ne parvenait pas à freiner
deux personnes fauchées sur la route
sont mortes dans cet accident le nouveau
patron de Twitter Elon Musk avait promis
de rouvrir le compte de Donald Trump sur
le réseau social il l'a fait en
s'appuyant sur un vote de ses abonnés la
majorité des 15 millions d'internautes
qui se sont exprimés ont répondu
favorablement l'ancien président n'a pas
dit s'il comptait de nouveau utiliser ce
canal de communication
j'aime bien c'est un personnage j'ai
tendance à aimer les personnages j'avais
toujours rêvé de devenir une vedette que
je pouvais absolument fantastique de
de devenir une vedette de pouvoir être
reconnu comme ça à gauche et à droite et
je peux dire que j'ai connu cette
fantastique enivrement pendant quelques
temps d'être connu d'être connu donner
des autographes de faire semblant de
voir la pression je veux dire de faire
plaisir aux gens du fait qu'on existait
c'est quoi maintenant je m'appelle
soulaymane
est-ce que tu pratiques ou pas du tout
non mais je respecte beaucoup je
m'intéresse et je pense que les
religions sauveront le monde au sens où
ce qui croit mais de son meilleur
sens de la raison qui partait à chaque
pas sur le devant de la scène
sort de la vie que je
vais et je l'aime
je suis pas religieux mais je suis
spirituel voilà je suis spirituel c'est
à dire que tu es un escroc en fait
s
je vais faire le ramadan pour la
première fois là
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde est le bienvenu c'est une
invitation pour le monde entier
accueilli par un jeune homme handicapé
le discours prône la tolérance
je peux le voir ce qui nous unit ici en
ce moment l'emporte de loin sur ce qui
nous sépare
c'est beau ouais ça me fait plaisir
ah ça c'est un côté musulman c'est
Jean-Marie Bigard
vous pouvez tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh tu m'as fait beaucoup de peine elle
est là elle est par là
bonjour mon cher Laurent